alright former gymnast and sexual
assault survivor survivor Rachel den
Hollander set off one of the largest
investigations of its kind in US history
she was the first to publicly accuse
former USA gymnastics team dr. Larry
Nasser of abuse
more than 150 survivors later came
forward Nasser was sentenced to up to a
hundred and 75 years in prison then
Hollander was 15 years old when she was
first treated by Nasser she gave the
last victim impact statement at his
trial last year this is what it looks
like when institutions create a culture
where a predator can flourish unafraid
and unabated and this is what it looks
like when people in authority refused to
listen put friendships in front of the
truth failed to create or enforce proper
policy and fail to hold enablers
accountable this is what it looks like
this is what it looks like indeed in her
new book den Hollander explains what led
her to speak out against her abuser it's
called what is a girl worth love the
title my story breaking the silence and
exposing the truth about Larry Nasser
and USA Gymnastics she's also written a
children's book called how much is a
little girl worth Rachael den Hollander
joins us first on CBS this morning
Rachel welcome thank you I've just said
your book was chilling graphic and
heartbreaking to read but I'd love that
you really took us inside the room
because here you are 15 years old and
you get an appointment with the doctor
who's called the best of the best and on
that very first visit you are abused
what happens yeah Larry began
penetrating me on the very first visit
and I think this is something that we
really need to take away from the story
is the role that the community plays
because the reality is I didn't just
trust my abuser ayuh trusted the
institutions that surrounded him I
trusted the community that surrounded
him I knew as I was laying there I was
not his first victim but as you're
walking down to his office there's all
these pictures of Olympians that are
smiling so you're thinking they're all
coming here the thing that really gets
me though Rachael's your mom was in the
room yeah how is that possible your
mom's in the room
yeah Larry was very skilled and he used
other relationships that we held the
most year against us he would block her
view so he couldn't so she couldn't see
what he was doing of course I didn't
realize that you know and my thought
process was there's no way that someone
hasn't described to MSU in two USAG what
Larry's doing and if there's any
question about this treatment surely
someone would do something and I trusted
not just Larry I trusted the
institutions and the authority figures
that surrounded him and I didn't realize
that 15 how misplaced that trust was you
also right you went through something
similar in your own church mm-hmm and
you right that it left me with a lesson
I've never forgotten and that in fact
took into the exam room with Larry if
you can't prove it don't speak up
because it will cost you everything
that's a lesson every sexual assault
survivor knows we watch how sexual
assault is discussed when it comes up in
the political sphere when it comes up
with a prominent sports figure and we
see what people say about those
survivors we see how they rally around
the person who's been the abuser and we
know it's not safe to speak up but even
when I went to a coach to say listen
this happened to me she told you listen
we can't verify it maybe you better not
say anything what does that say our
about our culture Rachel yeah I think it
says a lot of things first and foremost
that we still really absorb a lot of
cultural myths about rape and sexual
abuse and I think it's something else we
really need to learn from this is that
you know in a blurs don't look like a
bunch of men sitting in a smoke-filled
cigar room saying we think child rape is
fine and we're gonna let it go on more
often than not if someone in our
community who desires to do the right
thing but has not taken the time to
learn what the right thing is and
doesn't understand the dynamics of abuse
so when they receive a disclosure they
respond in a way that silences the
survivor and causes an insurmountable
damage so Michigan State which was under
a dozen federal and state investigations
told us in a statement that for the
investigations that have concluded we
are fully committed to accepting the
responsibility of change and
accountability in the findings and
reports what does responsibility and
accountability look like to you it
hasn't happened yet
it absolutely not has not happened not
with either organization every
investigation that's been done they
either have refused to comply with by
not waiving attorney-client privilege
and releasing the facts or they it's
been done with significant arm-twisting
you know taking responsibility looks
like what I require my little children
to do to say I am sorry that and to
identify the fail
and to identify the harm that was caused
and then ask how can I make it right he
also said that he was terribly sorry
Larry Nasser said that he was terribly
sorry that he was ready that he wanted
healing but at the end when it came to
sentencing sentencing he took no
responsibility what did his words you
heard him plead guilty and you heard him
say he was terribly sorry what did that
mean to you after all of this you know
to hear Larry admit what he did was a
gift that I really never thought I would
get it's a gift that most survivors
don't get and I don't take that for
granted
that being said I had reached a point
where my healing was no longer dependent
on that because when you're dealing with
an abuser you're dealing with a
consummate manipulator and so I knew
that my healing couldn't be dependent on
what Larry said or did and I think what
we saw with Larry is exactly what we
needed to see we saw the power of
manipulation how an abuser can turn on
the tears how many end even in the USA
Gymnastics told us that the process for
addressing reports of sexual misconduct
is stronger and better defined they also
said it made changes like mandatory
reporting and policies that set
boundaries between staff and athletes
are you satisfied with what they've done
well their last two appointees were
already under investigation in safe
sport for having abusive environments in
their gym and they didn't manage the
catch that before they appointed them or
didn't think it was a problem before
they put them in charge of athletes
safety so if you have to be told to do a
background check on your new appointees
three years into the worst sexual
assault scandal in sports history I
don't think you've learned very much
going forward Rachel I think this is
important you said it's okay not to know
what to do for people who are concerned
but what but you have to ask yeah you
have not okay not to ask absolutely
Rachel den Hollander thank you so much
for being with us